what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so getting into dark side versus
Galactus this creates kind of a weird
situation and the reason why I say that
is when the Marvel vs. DC stories were
first introduced or they were first
launched with Superman and spider-man we
were told that originally these
characters just shared a singular
universe that it was not the main DC or
the main continuity Superman it wasn't
the main Marvel continuity spider-man
they were wholly separate and they share
their own different reality but as time
progressed Marvel and DC had this sort
of silent change in the sense that
somewhere along the line it stopped
being a shared universe and they were
two separate universes now again it was
not like it was the main DC Universe and
the main Marvel Universe it was just a
separate DC universe and a separate
Marvel Universe out there somewhere on
the multiverse and they just started
crossing over with one another but the
idea here was that the story at least
seems to be an instance where maybe is a
shared universe maybe it's not a shared
universe again Marvel and DC don't
really answer the question that answer
didn't really come until the Marvel DC
crossover which you'll find down in the
description out a video to that but the
mobile DC crossover gave us two
different gods one God for Marvel one
God for DC they were brothers
something along those lines and
eventually they merged and formed the
amalgam universe we was just a
combination of Marvel and DC characters
combined into one single character so
like dark cloth for example his Batman
Wolverine but the idea here is that this
really initiative at least the way John
Byrne writes any way it initially picks
up with the origin of apocalypse and the
origin of New Genesis that is to say the
planets of Darkseid and highfather now
for the sake of clarity but we're not
gonna go with the origin as presented
here we're gonna go with the origin for
the new 52 just for the sake of the fact
that if you know somebody watches this
video and then they pick up with another
you know new god video that I did or
something like that they won't be
confused on the origins so the way it is
now anyway the way the Geoff Johns went
back in and changed it is that
originally there was just a plan there
was a singular planet out there
somewhere on the multiverse and this
planet was inhabited by just some native
race and they were basically worshippers
of these elder gods and these Elder Gods
represented their base emotions so it
was like the elder god of Wrath the
older God of
love the older god of chaos so on and so
forth eventually what had happened was a
farmer named u k-- SAS rose up against
these elder gods started killing them
and then absorbing their power and that
basically led to the - u k-- SAS
becoming dark side on the other half of
the equation
you had u s-- asses brother-in-law and
his name escapes me at the moment uh but
the last of the elder gods bestowed
their power on to you classes
brother-in-law and he became high father
now because of the fact that high father
and dark started started waging war
against one another it eventually led to
the destruction of this planet and in
response they formed their own
individual planets Darkseid created a
planet of death destruction and misery
in the form of apocalypse and then
highfather formed a planet of love
basically took whatever inhabitants were
left on the planet that was destroyed
they previously inhabited and they all
basically took up residence on new
Genesis and so while it is kind of a
planet of love is really more of like
the most earth-like planet and since
they have an organized society they have
a hierarchy in terms of power structure
so on and so forth but it's really more
for like science exploration that kind
of thing now the way that this also gets
interesting is that while you had those
new gods you also had another guy named
met Ron and met Ron was neither of New
Genesis nor of Apocalypse no one knows
where he came from he was just there one
day he doesn't really have a
tried-and-true definitive origin story
as far as I'm aware instead he's really
like DC's version of The Watcher from
Marvel Comics he travels around he
chronicles what he sees he stores that
information and what's called the Mobius
chair and then it's just kind of rinse
repeat the issue with this is that
because the new gods of dark side and
and highfather were so powerful their
ongoing war that they had would have led
to the ruin of the multiverse itself and
so what Metron did is he went to each of
them and said in order to create a
lasting truce you're going to switch
sons the son of new Genesis I guess the
son of high father named scott-free is
going to travel to apocalypse and he's
going to live there the son of Darkseid
named Orion is gonna go to a new Genesis
and he's gonna look there and the hope
of Metron was that because you know
Darkseid and and highfather because
their sons were living on the other's
planet that it would keep them from
attacking each other because they
wouldn't want to destroy their sons and
basically eliminate any chance for you
know their legacy to live on it so this
maintained a lasting peace for quite
some time but what that does is kind of
bring us to the current moment right now
again this is really the idea that it
seems as though their Sharon universe
the reason why I say this is because of
the fact this silver surfer is basically
on the hunt for planets for Galactus to
consume now the kicker about all this is
that this treats silver surfer really it
kind of takes him outside what we're
used to in the sense that with silver
surfers history after Norrin Radd became
the surfer he basically adopted a
morality he came to realize what his
past was he came to realize who we used
to be and that's why as time progressed
he began the process of taking up taking
Galactus to planets that did not have
life heard it really didn't have Cynthia
in life they were just capable of
supporting life that would develop at
some point along lawn that's what that's
one reason why he started doing this
what this story says is that's not the
case Silver Surfer never learned about
his past he doesn't know anything about
his history and because of that he's
just on a mission to send Galactus to
planets that have the ability to satiate
his hunger whether or not they have
sentient life now with him coming across
new Genesis what happens here is new
Genesis begins to panic because they
know who Galactus is and they say if
Galactus comes here he's going to
consume our planet but what New Genesis
does is actually really really smart
they actually end up grabbing a a
character named light wave and they have
him really have them distract or at
least trick Galactus and the reason why
I say that is um New Genesis always use
what was called the source as a means to
see what was going on around them or
basically to answer questions they
weren't able to gain answers to on their
own and the sources is just like the
source of everything is this weird
mysterious thing there's no real answers
on what the source is a lot of people
just say it's God basically but when New
Genesis contacts the source and says
what should we do that Galactus is
coming their answer is hide the world do
something because if he knows you're
there who's going to consume your planet
and there's nothing you can do to stop
him
and so what happens is New Genesis
basically uses a character named light
wave now light wave is this new God that
basically is able to harness the power
of stars that's really what he is I mean
he can travel faster than the speed of
light he can create you know illusions
using light he can bolster the powers of
Superman to the IMP degree using his
ability to harness solar energy but what
he can do is use his power over light
tikrit to basically hide a new Genesis
to make it look like a star and the
reason why is because Galactus does not
consume stars he doesn't do that just
because the fact that stars cannot
sustain life they you know help bolster
life in in solar systems but nothing
grows on stars and so because of that
the Silver Surfer sees what looks like
it started him by
is it in troubles to the planet
apocalypse now when he gets there he's
immediately attacked by parademons no
it's not just like the para demons
attack them arbitrarily because they
don't know what he is the pair of demons
attack the Silver Surfer because
Darkseid told them to
because Darkseid is aware of the fact
that Galactus is coming now for Darkseid
himself it is a little bit of panic here
this is one of the reasons why the
story's so well known is because dark
side is usually fearless but Darkseid is
never confronted Galactus before and so
it's like these two beings of absolute
power facing off against one another and
so far they confer Darkseid is entirely
possible that apocalypse may be
destroyed but the funny thing about this
is that Darkseid also has a bit of
information that galactus doesn't he
kind of has a little piece of
information it'll become extremely
important once the story begins to wrap
up but with regards to - it's a Galactus
showing up here of course as he always
does the first thing is just begin the
process of landing on apocalypse and
building his world devouring machine now
the funny thing about this is that you
know really Darkseid takes every bit of
every ounce of technology every bit of
the planet apocalypse that he controls
and throws it against Galactus I mean he
has his own servants that the citizens
of his own planet go against Galactus
and every last one of them are totally
obliterated in addition to this it's
really just the idea of the parademons
facing off against Silver Surfer they're
all being defeated left and right but
eventually we also have at least what
seems to be a Ryan getting involved now
the reason why I ryan gets involved in
this particular event is is twofold
first because of the fact that basically
Darkseid is his father and Orion follows
the Warriors code so for him if there is
battle to be had he will be at that
battle that's just the way it is where
the character will riot more so than
that Darkseid and highfather represent
good and evil they're basically
necessities in the realm of the DC
multiverse if one of them were to perish
the balance of good and evil would fall
out of balance as well and that's well
it reasons why dark sides character is
so cool is because he's always on the
hunt for the anti-life equation the
ability to dominate the Wills of
everybody that he comes across but he
kills a multitude of people he instills
anger he instills wrath in the people
that come across his path and so because
of that he's very much like Galactus in
the sense that Galactus consumes planets
because he has to because if he were to
die unrivaled evil would just permeate
into the Marvel Universe
Darkseid's much the same way it's just
what they stand for are two different
things but seeing a silver surfer gogans
go against Orion
a whole lot to be had here I'm initially
just kind of a battle between the two of
them Silver Surfer ultimately comes out
on top which again is really John Byrne
saying here's how silver silver stands
in comparison to the various other
characters in the DC landscape but what
we also have is the I guess really the
arrival of desaad now the side being
here is really kind of interesting
because he's one of these two guys it's
it kind of isn't really like a
chronicler of Darkseid so much he's like
they're basically like his generals you
have desaad and he have Steppenwolf but
with the character of desaad what he
does is grab the device and just throw
it on the Silver Surfer and it basically
gives him knowledge of everything that's
going on and this is when he realizes
his whole past about about you knows in
law the idea that you know Galactus has
basically gone back and consumed it
somewhere along the line different
things like that and so for him he feels
very betrayed with regards to Darkseid
as a character not only that we're also
met with the arrival of the black racer
now the black racer is this interesting
concept in DC Comics because some riders
have depicted the black racer it's just
the equivalent of death specific to the
flash and nobody else other riders have
depicted the black racer as just one of
the representations of death that when a
person dies the black racer finds their
soul and whisks them off to the
afterlife
is one of these weird kinds of things
but for the sake of this story John
Byrne is going with the overarching DC
concept in the sense that when someone
dies the black racer takes them off to
the afterlife those are the black racers
doing at this location the black racer
is just there to take the souls of all
these people who have been killed in
this battle and take them you know wish
them off to the afterlife now with
regards to the Silver Surfer because of
the fact that he's aware of zin law
because of fact he's aware of everything
he's sacrificed in order to become The
Herald of Galactus he basically turns on
he looks like Galactus and says oh my
god what have I done you know now that
I've got morality now that I know the
difference between good and evil right
and wrong I'm sitting here looking at
this and I'm saying I basically became
The Herald of Galactus and I've doomed
billions of people by taking him to
planets because keep in mind prior to
this awareness that he has now he was
just a guy following orders he had no
concept of good and evil
he had no concept of right or wrong for
him it was just the Galactus needs to
eat so I'll just take him to the
splendors of it so that he can eat but
now the weight of the billions of lives
that Galactus has ended by way of
consuming planets now rests on his
shoulders and because of that the Silver
Surfer attacks Galactus now forced in no
uncertain terms the Silver Surfer is
obliterated almost immediately but with
a distraction their dark side steps up
and Darkseid uses
Megan beams now this is a huge deal
because Darkseid's Omega beams are
virtually unstoppable I mean they're
almost completely unstoppable the number
of people who have been able to
withstand his Omega beams can be counted
on one hand and so for the most part is
kind of like you know when when Darkseid
shows up in DC Comics view a mega
station comes out the beams get blasted
on somebody they're gone I mean that's
they're they're dead that's just the way
it is there's really no coming back from
that but with with Galactus doesn't face
him and ounce I mean there's no effect
whatsoever he doesn't stun he doesn't
falter he doesn't take a couple steps
back he's not like wow you're powerful
he's just like get out of here with that
because as far as the logis is concerned
Darkseid is on the same level as the
parademons on the same levels you know
the peoples even funny so far it's it's
really you know an ant in the face of
cumin or something like that now this is
one of the things that proved really
controversial and a lot of DC fans
didn't like this they were really really
angry about that because they're like no
Darkseid is all-powerful Darkseid is one
of the most powerful beings in the
entirety of DC Comics how is he not
gonna face Galactus and that's kind of a
weird situation here in truth with John
Byrne riding it I wouldn't be surprised
if this was like a snub of sorts its
Wars DC Comics just because of the fact
that he kind of got a heart John Byrne
got a hard time when he was writing a
lot of the Superman mythos post-crisis
on Infinite Earths but I would say in
truth and in my mind I would say the
dark sides not you not nearly as much of
a pushover as he's being made out to be
here I wouldn't say he could destroy
Galactus but I would save you Omega beam
should be enough to cause a pretty good
amount of damage to Galactus I would say
that it wouldn't you know it wouldn't be
something were Colossians just kind of
be like man whatever don't really care I
wouldn't say they're even but I would
say it would do some damage enough that
Galactus would notice collide just to
say hey man this guy's pretty dangerous
but I would also say the other reason
why John Byrne pulls this is because of
the fact that Darkseid ultimately wins
here and the reason why is because
apocalypse is not a life-sustaining
planet it's not designed for that
purpose there are people who inhabit it
there but the only people who are there
Moreland's they're not gonna die they
don't really need food water different
things like that they can be killed by
Darkseid himself but in terms of the
grand scheme of things apocalypse is not
like earth you know it's not like some
life-sustaining planet the galoshes can
just show up and consume now when a
Galactus says this he says there's no
life energy here there's there's nothing
here why why didn't you tell me that in
the beginning why did you send all your
people there why did you send thousands
and
thousands of your citizens you know
against me for me to basically just
phased them out of existence using the
power cosmic and you know Darkseid says
well because it's my nature like I'm a
guy that just loves to see death and
destruction that so I'm about death and
destruction that's what I'm about that's
what I'm here for you know and so for
Darkseid he also says you know I just
wanted you to know that you basically
wasted your time here you know I wanted
you to show up here waste your time and
realize that you cannot destroy my
planet not because I'm all-powerful but
because of the fact that there's no
reason for you to be here now in
response Galactus is is short and quick
to this he's like man you're evil like
you're just an evil / you're just an
evil being that's just the most evil
thing that I've ever heard as so
Galactus basically just leaves because
there's no reason for him to be there
but it's really just kind of a this idea
that John Byrne's sitting down is saying
you know if the lockers were considered
to be an evil being you know because
he's going around and consuming planets
and killing billions of people if we
have to compare which one's more evil
Galactus or dark side dark side comes
out on top because he literally could
have told the lodge's at the beginning
of all this hey there's no reason for
you to be here this this place that'll
sustain there's no life-sustaining
energy there's an energy source but it
does you you can't consume it you know
you're basically trying to fit a square
peg into a round hole there's no reason
for you to be here he could have told
him that at the very beginning but he
didn't instead he just sent countless
people against Galactus and every last
one of them died and so again it's kind
of a crazy situation here but but yeah
this is just part one of the stories
that goes on the road to the eventual
Marvel vs. DC crossover event but if you
guys are new here to comics explain as
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all in it peace
[Music]